wat mogelijk is
met voeding
en hoe we eigenlijk voor de gek worden gehouden door
1 industrie die er baat bij heeft wanneer jij ziek bent
en dat heeft mij het vuur aangewakkerd om mensen
echt het motiveren
te stimuleren om aan de gang te gaan met hun
leefstijl en voeding
en dan merk je van wauw het
gezondheid is zoveel meer dan
alleen wat je wat je binnen krijgt
en natuurlijk is het belangrijk wat je eet
ik ZEG altijd
en kun je van 1
huis verwachten dat het 100 jaar blijft staan als je
gebruik maakt van slechte bouwmaterialen
hetzelfde geldt voor je lichaam
ja als je heel veel stress in je leven ervaart
conflictsituaties
familie ruzies noem maar op
je maakt je overal druk om ook met wat je eten
oh dit mag ik wel eten
dit niet en nee dit absoluut
ja hoe verwacht je dan dat er gezondheid ontstaat
dus het gaat echt om de balans
het holistische totale natuurlijk lichaam
geest en ziel
en als die met elkaar mooi in balans zijn dan
ja dan denk ik ook dat je vanuit 1 hogere
staat van bewustzijn
ook veel meer gezondheid kunt creëren in je leven